what else do you recall from your
breakfast Hamilton I ate it from a
ceramic bowl with a metal Fork
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start shake
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by Inc
tel and I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that in investing
as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant time Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my land rush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
and out and make your customers raving
fans so they answer more than a million
customer service requests every year and
they can do so across all platforms
including email phone social media text
even chat leaving your customers with
poor service or just mediocre service
which by the way in a competitive pool
is a huge liability long wait times or
unanswered messages carries a massive
cost and risk to your business Intel
removes the logistics and headaches of
this type of communication allowing you
to focus on your strengths and
grow your business it can be a real
competitive advantage and I see many
many e-commerce companies and tech
companies thinking of customer service
as a good enough check box or an
afterthought and just like Airbnb use
design in innovative ways to be a
competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off that's a big
discount ten thousand dollars off your
startup fees and costs by visiting Inc
Telecom forward slash Tim so check it
out for more info go to inc Telkom i NK
te l comm forward slash tim this episode
is brought to you by leadership in
turbulent times which is the latest book
by the ever amazing pulitzer
prize-winning author Doris Kearns
Goodwin I had her on the podcast not too
long ago and she just blew everyone away
what an incredible storyteller and
Weaver of history and lessons from
history you can check that out if you
want a tim dot blog forward slash doris
dr is it was a captivating conversation
that really blew me away leadership in
turbulent times that is the latest book
is a culmination of five decades of
acclaimed studies in presidential
history which offers an illuminating
exploration of the early development
that's super key early development
growth and exercise of leadership and
draws upon former presidents which we'll
get to in a second goodwin asks and
answers in those pages the questions are
leaders born or made
where does ambition come from how does
adversity affect the growth of
leadership does the leader make the
times or do the times make the leader
and she draws upon the four presidents
she has studied most closely namely
Abraham Lincoln Theodore Roosevelt
Franklin D Roosevelt and Lyndon B
Johnson to show how they recognize
leadership qualities within themselves
and were recognized as leaders by others
and I mentioned early development being
key because it goes back to their first
soldiers and experiments and attempts at
engaging with policy and public life and
covers their failures there
near misses and lessons learned so it
applies to anyone who is trying to make
a study of leadership or how they can
better lead both themselves and others
it's important to underscore that no
common pattern describes completely a
single trajectory of leadership although
set apart in background abilities and
temperament these four men shared a
fierce ambition and deep-seated
resilience that enabled them to surmount
uncommon hardships and that their best
all four were guided by a sense of moral
purpose this seminal work provides an
accessible and essential roadmap for
aspiring established leaders in every
field I highly highly recommend it for
more information you can visit Doris
Kearns Goodwin calm that's Doris Kearns
ke a RNs Goodwin calm and leadership in
turbulent times is available in
hardcover ebook and audio wherever books
are sold
check it out my head Mayo boys and girls
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show today's guest I'm gonna
keep this intro short and skip the
preamble because I'm so excited to share
this with you is Hamilton Morris on
Twitter at Hamilton Morris Instagram at
Hamilton Morris who is a writer
documentarian and scientific researcher
who currently studies the chemistry and
pharmacology of tryptamines what are
those we'll talk about it at the
University of the Sciences in
Philadelphia his writing has been
featured in Harper's Playboy and vice
and he is the creator of the television
series and oh my goodness do I love it
Hamilton's pharmacopoeia or
pharmacopoeia you don't have to worry
about spelling it's easy to find as soon
as you type in Hamilton's Pharma
anywhere that you want to find it
whether that's Amazon Prime or wherever
which recently completed its second
season and it is absolutely one of my
favorite series of last five years
I don't know how on earth took me so
long to find this it's fantastic and I
encourage you to check it out his
website which should be up by the time
this episode publishes I'm gonna keep
prodding him is Hamilton Morris dot-com
Hamilton is you think M Orr is dot-com
and this episode goes
into the chemistry of psychedelics and
mine altering substances his adventures
and misadventures around the world with
different indigenous cultures different
clandestine chemists and all sorts of
characters very very smart guy
exceptionally good at explaining complex
subjects simply and making science sexy
please mate Hamilton Morris Hamilton
welcome to the show
thanks for having me I have been hoping
to have this conversation on the podcast
ever since I first saw your show and
have recommended the show to probably
more people than any other show I've
seen in the last three to five years so
thank you for making it first of all
that's grandpa why do you like it and I
wanted to begin the conversation we're
going to bounce around a lot I will
mispronounce many many things
so please pardon my ignorance this has
been a trend already in our
conversations but I thought we could
start off by introducing people to a
character they may not know and that's
Alexander Shulgin and I think the best
way to do this is to read the opening of
the last interview with Alexander
Shulgin and here we go
I feel free to correct any of this Marty
I'm already feeling embarrassed before
you even start this is a pretty old
piece of writing oh okay
would you prefer that let me just get
through it is that okay it's okay yeah I
love Alexander Shulgin I've loved him
from the first moment I read about him
he is my idol my hero my son my o2 I
love each of the 978 pages of his fan
ethylamine magnum opus peak hall Fenella
means I have known and loved in every
milligram of his 1.1 3 kilogram
tryptamine treatise t call tryptamines I
have known and loved above my bed I've
pinned a large picture of Shulgin
cuddling with his wife and I often sleep
with a copy of peak all not under my
pillow but as my pillow he is the
grandfather of ecstasy the molecular
magician the atomic conquistador over
the span of 50 years he has created more
new psychedelic drugs than the Amazon
jungle ever has
is more of a mythological creature a
chemical scent or than he is a real
person who is Alexander Shulgin
Alexander Shulgin
is a chemist who has just a career so
amazing that you'd think he couldn't be
a real person he's very much a product
of the 1950s and I could you know tell
you is his life story in a condensed way
but I'll tend to do that very question
the basic story is that Alexander
Shulgin came from a poor family of
Russian immigrants in California and he
was accepted at Harvard as I think as an
unusually young freshman I think at that
time it was somewhat more common for
people that were very young to go to
college early and he felt alienated from
his classmates because they all had
money and he didn't and he made a small
bomb out of mercury fulminate and blew
up the windows of his freshman dormitory
and then decided to leave Harvard and
join the Navy and in the Navy he injured
his thumb and had to have a small
surgical procedure done to sew up the
wound and before the procedure a nurse
gave him a glass of orange juice that
had crystals of morphine that were
floating on the surface of the orange
juice and he drank it and passed out and
they sewed up the wound and when he
regained consciousness he thanked the
nurse and said thank you so much for
giving me that morphine that really made
the procedure painless and I don't think
I could have gotten through it without
the morphine and she said there was no
morphine
those were sugar crystals and that first
encounter with the placebo effect was so
profound for him that he realized he
wanted to dedicate the rest of his life
to understanding drugs in the mind and
when he was in the Navy he brought this
chemistry textbook with him by a chemist
named Paul
career and and studied it and you know
these are early chemistry textbooks they
had synthesis of masculine synthesis of
lysergic acid synthesis of Harmelin and
all these things were they weren't
treated as taboo subjects who were
simply legitimate areas of scientific
inquiry so he was being exposed to all
this chemistry that would later serve as
the foundation of his career and then he
got out of the Navy went to Berkeley got
a degree in biochemistry and started
working for Dow which then was in this
order it was a controversial time
because they were supporting the
manufacture of napalm in Vietnam and
there was all of this sort of political
protests surrounding the work but he had
developed a profitable insecticide
called Zek Tran and because he'd made
them all this money they said you can do
whatever you want
so while he was still working at Dow he
started making a variety of different
psychedelics and you can actually see
his doubt notebooks online with the Dow
logo and everything and at that point he
was not only synthesizing these things
but he was testing them on himself which
was the only effective way to do it and
at some point they decided they didn't
want him to do that anymore but he had
enough money that he decided to continue
the research in his backyard and he did
this all openly he didn't hide anything
he published in the most prestigious
scientific journals then and now nature
and science and he did it all from his
home address with no university
affiliation and he did amazing research
I mean there are entire pharmaceutical
companies that have done less than he
did in his backyard he is considered
responsible for reintroducing MDMA as a
psychotherapeutic tool in addition to
that he created countless derivatives of
MDMA he also created it
called Ariadne or Die Maximian that was
used as a potential treatment for senile
dementia created methylone which he
patented as an antidepressant I mean you
could go on and on and on about the
amazing contributions of this guy so
he's someone that you know you rarely
have these experiences in life for you
you can point them and say that changed
my life but I remember as a high school
student reading a profile of him in the
New York Times Magazine sitting in my
parents kitchen and thinking and I
wasn't even very interested in drugs I
mean I was maybe as intro I was probably
a little bit more interested than a than
a typical high school student but I
wasn't a druggie I had smoked salvia and
used cannabis a number of times and
drank alcohol a number of times but I
wasn't actively pursuing this and then I
read a profile of this guy and and
thought wow he is inventing not only new
drugs but new types of drugs drugs that
I didn't know existed and no one knew
existed he's doing in his backyard what
an amazing human being
what if totally fascinating creature
this person is and and became pretty
seriously obsessed with him you know
ordered his books read the books and the
books I think have had many levels to
them that you come to appreciate there's
the superficial level which is you read
these things and they're fantastic so
the best not just best books about drugs
ever written some of the best books
about science ever written so you know
if you're just interested in science I
can't recommend these are they
accessible to non chemists yes they're
absolutely
accessible to non chemists because
there's a narrative component to each
book a love story and stories that are
more accessible and then there's
hardcore chemistry as well so the
typical way somebody reads these books
is you read the stories and you read the
qualitative effects of the drugs and you
kind of skim over the chemistry because
it's too complicated and that's the way
I read it the first time as well and
then there's a kind of second reading
which is you know now you've taken or I
had
can you know general and organic
chemistry and now I'm ready to really
understand these things and then you
realize okay Wow all right this is this
is real and then the most amazing thing
then this is maybe what really has
reinforced my love for him is then
following some of these recipes in you
know in a university research laboratory
and realizing this is real this really
works this these are scientific tools
and the synthesis that he provided are
not only effective they're often
brilliant routes to producing these
compounds and what an amazing
contribution this man made what made him
so good in the sense that presumably
other people had access to the same
books and similar training I don't know
what what distinguishes a great chemist
from a merely good chemist well he would
actually often say that he was a
terrible chemist because his PhD was not
in chemistry he was he was more
interested in biochemistry and enzymes
and things like that and that's an
interest that carries over into a lot of
his later work and in certain ways but
what made him great is not so much the
chemistry itself although that was
fantastic and I would never suggest that
it wasn't but what made him great was he
had a perspective on science that a lot
of people don't have a lot of people
they think whatever they're doing right
now is state-of-the-art because it is
and they don't think well what if this
fMRI stuff we're doing right now what if
a decade from now it's all garbage and
what if this was a huge very expensive
waste of time but what's the one thing
that won't be a waste of time what's
what is certain to be timeless and
that's experience that's the one thing
that never becomes obsolete and he
understood that if he had been like so
many of his colleagues and said oh wow I
just discovered a new derivative of
mescaline
I can't wait to cut out a strip of a
rat's uterus
and place it in a bath and see if this
masculine derivative causes the strip of
uterus to contract this will be so
interesting to find out well all the
research that has was done on isolated
uterus tissue and things like that it's
all obsolete
you can't cite that in a scientific
paper in a meaningful way without kind
of understanding that it's not
considered useful because it doesn't
differentiate between the different
subtypes of serotonin receptors and
there's so many variables to consider so
he understood all that that these
pharmacological assays were flawed but
his own experience was the bottom line
that's what mattered and and there have
been a number of philosophers that I
think had a similar attitude you know
Goethe also wrote this amazing book on
colors I don't know if you know about
this book but he he's I know of it I
haven't read it I have a friend who's a
memory competitor who's who has read
this and recommended it to me well it's
a really amazing idea I've been reading
it recently and you know he was saying
physicists are saying the color is made
of waves of light or these different
theories but what difference does it
make we don't experience colors waves of
light so why don't we take our own
experience as seriously as the
physicists that are measuring the
wavelengths of each color of light and
why don't I sit and describe the
experience of green and sit and describe
the experience of yellow and what it's
like and what does it look like during
the day and what does it look like at
night and how does it change everything
everything that I can observe and to not
underestimate my perceptual apparatus as
a sort of analytical device how
generalizable what is the value of the
subjective experience or describing that
experience and how generalizable is it I
mean you mentioned color so it makes me
think of how certain cultures treat and
perceive colors very differently right
of course in the in the case of saya
shulgin or others would you see in the
value or what did he see in the value of
describing the subjective experience and
I'm sure the question a lot of people
are wondering is
how the hell did he risk mitigating like
if he's creating these novel compounds
how did how do you think about risk in
such a case right and that's a that's a
great question there's two ways to think
about the risk issue there's one way
that you could say like how could how
could he possibly have done this it was
so dangerous he was the first person to
synthesized these things no one knew
anything about them they hadn't even
been given to rodents yet so how could
he possibly take that risk the flipside
is do we really know anything about any
drugs that we take I mean there's still
fundamental debate going on right now
about whether or not cannabis decreases
IQ after long-term use I mean I have the
psychopharmacology textbook that I was
using when I was in college says that it
does then there's endless debate about
it we haven't resolved very basic
aspects of the toxicity of the most
widely used drugs on earth so I would
say before we magnify the potential
danger in unknown substances we
shouldn't minimize the potential danger
in the known substances because really
everything is unknown to a certain
extent and the the basic way that he
mitigated that risk and he actually
published a scientific article
describing his methodology that's worth
reading for anyone that wants to get
into this area is to start small to
start at 1/10 of whatever the absolute
smallest imaginable those might be for
something so if it's a you know suppose
you made that's just completely
hypothetical suppose you made six methyl
DMT six methyl DMT is likely to be
inactive it probably won't have any
activity but just to be safe if I were
hypothetically making that I might want
to start at a hundred micrograms all
evidence would point to it being less
potent than DMT but why risk it started
100 nothing in an hour
move up to two
then move up to 400 and then over the
course of days very gradually escalate
the dose and if you do it that way you
can say with a pretty high level of
certainty that you won't poison yourself
because even if it were cyanide you
wouldn't poison yourself if you were
doing it that way
you would recognize that it was toxic
before you reached anything close to a
lethal dose of the material the same
would be true of strychnine there are
very few which you wouldn't advise which
I would not advise people although Sirk
9 has been used medicinally in the past
and I would actually be curious about
trying it at a low dose but but maybe
this just shows the sort of person I am
what would people search for if they
wanted to find that that methodology in
his description of it I believe it was
published in the Journal of
psychopharmacology and I think it's
called any type of gingerbread trail and
we can put it in the in the show notes
but we can give it a I can definitely
pull it out for you quickly with a
Google search I can't remember off the
top of my head in fact yeah no problem
well and for people listening we'll put
that in the show notes and also for
people listening a quick audio engineer
note here in my sound studio this is the
hour of the blue jay so if you hear any
birds in the background those are blue
cheese and it is my kitchen table
Shulgin he's captured my fascination in
the last few years but part of me is may
be embarrassed or insecure about picking
up this book beyond the narratives
because I know no chemistry never taken
a chemistry class how would you
recommend or would you recommend to
people who are out of school who would
like to gain a basic literacy in
chemistry is there any particular
protrude that you would recommend
definitely yeah yeah I mean I think this
is a great time to learn anything
there's so many educational resources
available to people on the internet so
you know when I was taking organic
chemistry there are two books called
organic chemistry as a second language
part 1 and part 2
those are fent
astok very well-written very clear very
accessible do you need any are there any
prerequisites before reading this or can
you drop right into it just depends I
would say on your basic foundational
scientific literacy I would say for most
people that have let's say high school
level understanding of chemistry in the
sense that they you know know about
elements and things like that that
should be accessible I believe it's been
a little while since I've looked at it
but I remember it being pretty
accessible and then there's Khan Academy
videos that are very good as well and
there's a kind of an industry there's
actually a pretty big educational
industry surrounding organic chemistry
specifically because it's a class that's
taken by a lot of people that don't want
to be taking it right because it's a
pre-med requirement so the an industry
has emerged to help all of these pre-med
students who don't want to become
chemists and don't find chemistry
interesting to ensure that they can pass
the class so they can go to med school
which is nice because the same isn't
true for some other technical things
that this is really a purely a product
of the pre-med requirement I believe I
remember having another scientist had
spoken with nob on a prior episode of
with Peter Tia for people who've
listened his podcast for a while we've
you've seen these characters recur had
recommend actually getting the test prep
books for some of these related subjects
I think it was something or rather 101
that was all in a Q&A format but the
organic chemistry is a second language
will be on the shopping list definitely
get that and then the other thing is you
know I'm a I learn about things when I
have a practical application for them
there's a lot of things that as an
abstract idea don't have a lot of value
so and I say this with some hesitation
but you know if you really want to learn
these things the absolute best way to
learn them is to do chemistry
ideally in such a way that you don't
hurt yourself or other people or get
arrested but there's a lot of basic
chemistry work
like distillation that you can do and
it's a lot of fun to distill essential
oils or to extract various things from
plants you know you could extract
piperine from black pepper or or a
number of different things and that's
not illegal and it gives you a basic
idea of how to do these sorts of
chemical manipulations yeah I mean I
think that if I didn't have experience
working in a lab I don't think I could
ever care about chemistry as much as I
do because you need that practical
application typically to really dig deep
into something when did psychedelics
enter your life experience and why why
has it stuck and held your interest for
so long I was always aware of them and
always interested in them even as a
child you know I remember there's a book
called buzzed that was a sort of like I
think my school library had a copy of it
and it was a an educational drug book
and they had a section about DMT and it
and I remember even as a maybe a fifth
or a sixth grader thinking oh wow this
DMT stuff it's called they call it the
business man's trip on the street and
that that sure sounds interesting and I
remember that I don't even know if this
place still exists but there's a
shopping mall called the garage and
Harvard Square I grew up in Cambridge
and I remember a drug dealer approaching
me at the garage and saying do you want
some LSD and I said well I don't really
want LSD but I would like some DMT if
you have that consumer of street
psychedelics probably 12 or something
like that and but but but it didn't he
didn't of course and I didn't take the
LSD but I was aware that they had a
certain power my my dad was very afraid
of them he
child psychiatrist had written some
medical papers about how damaging it is
for people to use LSD as children and so
he had been very much influenced by his
psychiatrist who had led him to believe
that LSD was dangerous
so he had a I would say pretty
permissive attitude toward most things
but he really felt like he would say you
know don't take LSD promise me you won't
take LSD and and I had I went to a kind
of alternative high school and there was
also there a little bit of a sense that
psychedelics didn't necessarily do
people any favors you know a lot of the
people that use psychedelics weren't
people that I wanted to be like it
wasn't you know the I was I was pretty
nerdy guy was on a science team and
certainly no one on the science team was
using psychedelics and and and so I was
afraid of them and simply didn't use
them in a major way in high school other
than salvia which I actually loved and
although I was fascinated by them and
their been their power
how did salvia enter your life what was
the what was what was the first
experience because for better or worse
it was very available at that time and
had shops and so it was the sort of
thing that high school students would
talk about you know there's this stuff
it's it's legal you can buy it in stores
you smoke it it causes you to trip
dramatically for a few minutes and then
you're back to normal I mean it's a
pretty good sales pitch if someone's a
14 year old and and so I tried it and
this was also before people considered
it as frightening as they consider it
now there wasn't this fear narrative
surrounding the substance and I tried it
and it was utterly amazing and you know
that was my first experience beginning
to appreciate that these things were not
only very different from the way they
had been described but to some extent
they were not describable to begin with
no matter who was describing them there
was going to have to be some degree of
distortion and it really was the sort of
thing that had to be experienced and
then I started to understand a little
bit more about culturally why these
things are misunderstood and why they
might have more potential than people
realize why is that why why do you think
they're called well let me mention two
things number one is that before people
listening run out to find their local
salvia distributor watch a few YouTube
videos I mean it's it's worth being
cautious about I find I find salvia
divinorum fascinating and the science
equally fascinating but it it is fairly
well known for people who jump into it
without doing a whole lot of reading as
something that people do once in many
cases you tend to or in some cases like
to run away to check out the YouTube
videos first but secondly why are these
why are these substances cultured and
culturally misunderstood what are the
part of it I need to do with there being
no place for it I think you know what
what do we do with a salvia experience
it's a little bit weird to even talk
about it for a lot of people so what do
you do with it it doesn't fit into any
spiritual or religious frameworks in our
culture we don't have a framework for
there scientifically at least at that
time it was barely studied I think when
I first used it it may have been before
they even understood that it was a Kapo
opioid receptor agonist or anything
about it so there isn't a lot to do with
them so they've become marginalize to
almost because there's nowhere else for
them but the margins it's you know what
you do you can write a narrow it
experience report and tell your friends
about it and then that's the end of it
but the potential of course extends far
beyond that and these are really
important tools for studying
consciousness and in certain cultures or
even in our own if you develop a
framework to do it could be
the ways of treating disease or having a
spiritual type experience what would you
consider yourself and this is not a
trick question there's no right answer
here but since you use the word I say to
be spiritual a spiritual person I am NOT
a spiritual person at all in fact I am
not even sure I know what the word
spiritual means me neither yeah so in
that in that case what is their value or
what is their value in the spiritual
experience for someone like yourself yes
or I don't know it's it's lacking a
better descriptor I mean I recognize it
maybe that's not the right word to use
but I don't I don't know how else to
label it well there's a very tangible
value which is that you know along with
the visual distortions and the
distortions of time and sense of self
there's often these very simple positive
things that emerge like a sense of love
from my parents something like that love
for my friends appreciation for being
alive gratitude a desire to work hard to
use the time that I have on earth in a
way that will benefit other people you
know these are basic things that
sometimes emerge from the experience and
to feel those things in a in a genuine
way is fantastic it's really good
especially if you are a somewhat cynical
materialist person and when I say
materialist I don't mean in the like a
quiz ative yes sense of the media but
just in a sense do you believe in
physical reality as the ultimate be-all
end-all and and it doesn't change that
belief but it gives me a sense that
within that physical reality there is
tremendous depth and beauty and so many
things worthy of exploration we were
chatting a little bit yesterday about
about something that I'd love to to dig
into which is very closely related and
is suppose reflective of some trouble
I've had with interacting with various
types of explorers in this realm meaning
scientists on one hand if if I can
simplify it if these are hard scientists
on one end of the spectrum who almost
like I say universally but very much
fall I would say in line with the type
of thinking you're describing and then
on the other end of the spectrum people
coming from looking at psychedelics from
a for lack of a better adjective
shamanic perspective and it's it's hard
to get there there seems to be a l'heure
G's on both sides to the other in some
cases what is the what is what are the
reservations that you have about aside
from not believing in the Dede spirits
or whatever might be used for explaining
things on the shamanic side it seems to
be many people in these psychedelic
experiences want that type of context or
they seek say the shaman of one type or
another to provide them with this
container and experience and even people
were otherwise would view themselves as
very hyper rational how do you think
about the sort of shamanic cultural
context we lack it here but there are
cultures where that does exist but it
comes along with a lot more right that's
a complicated question there's there's a
lot of aspects to it that I find
slightly problematic one is that plants
are the be all and all I think that
plants are a wonderful starting place
and they introduce us to so many things
and maybe those things are the best
maybe DMT is as good as it gets but I've
had the opportunity to try a number of
different DMT derivatives MIT MPT DPT
dipt and so on ni PT and a number of
others and and what I can say about
having tried all these different
tryptamine derivatives of DMT is that
they have different properties and might
be better for different things
that we don't need to use these in a
one-size-fits-all manner so for example
people often talk about ego death for
whatever reason don't even like using
these psychoanalytic terms when
describing psychedelic experience but
for whatever reason with DMT it tends to
be about me about my life my friends my
family my associations with DPT it feels
more universal it feels like this is an
experience that anyone my DPT experience
could offend your DPT experience or
could have been anyone in the world CPT
experience because it's not about me
it's about it's not about my life it's
about life and and I think with the
shamanic route there's often a lot of
dogma there's a lot of this is the way
to do it and this is what's traditional
and there's a little bit of
discouragement of experimentation in
favor of what is traditional and that's
fantastic because we have a lot to learn
from these traditions without question
an enormous amount to learn but I don't
think we've figured it out I don't think
any culture has figured it out and I am
most in favor of any one that is
continually trying to push things
forward trying to see how can they be
even better than they are how can they
and that's maybe not a good mindset
maybe it's better to just be satisfied
but this is you know maybe that's the
scientific mindset how can we change it
how can we make it better for people
that don't like to vomit how can we make
it better for people that want a shorter
experience or people that are sensitive
to this or that and I mean we we chat
about this a little bit yesterday also
the not just the specificity of action
or being able to use derivatives for
different types of experiences but also
the reliability or accuracy of dosing
right yes
which maybe you could yeah you could
chat about for a second yeah I mean I
think that if there's one thing that is
not talked about enough in the
of psychedelics and drugs in general
it's dose dose is so so important to
understanding a drugs effect and it's
often not even discussed you know people
will say oh I hate it at all I hated
this I hated that I don't say oh really
you hate it at all how much did you how
much were you taking and they'll say oh
I don't know a pill
well there's 20 milligram pills and
there's five milligram pills and which
one were you taking and and it makes a
big difference it makes a huge
difference is you know the toxicology is
founded on this idea Paracelsus is idea
that the dose is the poison that the
difference between a medicine and a
poison is the dose and with plants you
don't have that luxury of knowing the
dose you simply don't there's tremendous
variability then on top of that they're
often being prepared in one way or
another that can make it even harder to
know exactly how much is being consumed
and then someone drinks a cup of brew
and they say I don't like ayahuasca it's
too strong or I didn't feel anything I'm
not sensitive to ayahuasca and what's
sad about that is you can't learn from
the experience because you don't know
what you took in the first place whereas
if they had taken 45 milligrams of DMT
freebase and a synthetic maoi then you
could say interesting maybe you're
unusually insensitive to DMT next time
try 55 milligrams and work your way up
gradually and eventually you'll find the
dose that works for you and that's and
you can kind of troubleshoot the
psychedelic experience it doesn't need
to be just a I felt it or I didn't feel
it was too much or wasn't enough thing
you can figure out what works for you
and that's really important because
these are serious experiences there's a
lot of uncertainty going into these
experiences at the very least to have
that foundation of I know what I took
and I know how much of it I took is
something that can't be underestimated
in its value there's so many different
directions I want to go but I'll try to
pick one and just binge is one more
thing in that vein that's the real
tragedy of psychedelics right now is for
a common person they have access to two
psychedelics
LSD and psilocybin containing mushrooms
and they don't know the dose of either
of those things
you take one bottle of LSD maybe someone
told you that it contains 100 micrograms
of LSD but you have no idea
I have analyzed blotters of non LSD
containing like Sergio mine's like 1 P
LSD blotter I was working with a chemist
friend on an experiment and there's
variation across the blotter then on top
of that there are different salts of
these different things these different
my Sergio mines so it's you don't know
how much you're taking to begin with
making the assumption that it's exactly
100 micrograms per blotter is a huge
mistake you have no idea and the same is
true of mushrooms even the same species
growing on the same substrate there can
be variation in potency between two
different mushrooms there can be
variation in potency across the same
mushroom between the stem and the calf
so in just just for sake of clarity when
you say variation and potency we're not
talking like a 10% difference in potency
there's a chemist named Joe Sheehan I
believe that two per institution carts
and he did he published some work on so
you can see exactly how much variation
he observed there hasn't been as much
research on it as I would like but the
the general takeaway is that is that
these things are not homogeneous and and
if you're going into what is potentially
a very profound experience you really
want to have that baseline confidence
that I took this much of something and I
think it really helps and is not to be
underestimated but I've been
particularly if you're coming in as many
people would with a reasonable level of
anxiety or fear or apprehension about
something that you've never experienced
that people describe suppose this may be
an oxymoron the describe is ineffable
are there any books you would recommend
or resources that you could recommend to
people aside from Shogun's books for
those who would like to learn more about
psychedelics and you mentioned
consciousness I'm wondering if there are
any books that you've found very
thought-provoking that don't also
activate your gag reflex given
yeah sort of the squishy nature of some
of that some of the writing right
there's one book that I think um hits
all those points you just made that's
really fantastic was written by my
thesis adviser Nikolas Lang wits and the
name of the book is neuro psych Adalia
it's an academic book so it's not it's
not as readable as maybe some of as
Michael Pollan's book for example but I
think it's one of the best books ever
written about psychedelics neuroscience
and consciousness and what was his last
name again Lange lits and he's a really
interesting guy MD PhD you know really
um very dedicated to understanding the
subject and he looks at it it came out
almost a decade before the Michael
Pollan book but it also takes a very
different perspective on the value of a
lot of the neuro imaging research so I
think it's a fantastic book that I can't
recommend enough you know for those that
are interested in the historical and
anthropological aspects of all of this
you have there's an anthropologist named
Douglas Sharon who wrote a lot about San
Pedro he's fantastic
there's Marlene dobkin de Rios who wrote
a lot about ayahuasca in the 80s and
maybe even in the late seventies she's
fantastic
there is of course Jonathan aught who
wrote pharmaco Theon he's fantastic and
has written many books and he's great
for getting a sort of wide historical
and scientific view of things I think he
was one of the best for that great I
will put all those in the show notes for
folks so you'll have links to all of
those why put together the TV show why
do so much work
I mean having some understanding based
on our conversation also just watching
the show you realize how much work it is
to put something like that together why
do I do it
I wanted to do it for a number of
reasons one is that I've always felt
that even that there's certain there
trends in journalism and that certain
things become demonized and then
everyone talks about how terrible they
are and then the public decides that's
truly the case so you know right now no
one could write an article about opioids
being good you simply couldn't do that
it's not wouldn't be allowed you would
be violently attacked by it you can
easily write an article about how
psilocybin is good and you will be
congratulated for doing that and I
started thinking about what things can
and can't be talked about in what can I
talk about the no one else is going to
talk about it and the main thing that I
was interested in with the show is
clandestine drugs synthesis that's sort
of the thing that I feel is most widely
misrepresented in the media are the
people that run underground drug labs so
somebody at Johns Hopkins if they're
doing research with psilocybin were very
eager to congratulate them for their
work but someone who's actually
responsible for providing these drugs to
the public so that someone normal people
can use them we're eager to demonize
them even though they're risking their
freedom to do that and they're typically
not bad people and in many cases they're
very good idealistic aliy motivated
people that do this because they think
it's the right thing to do with their
lives they really believe in it so I
thought okay with my understanding of
chemistry this would be a great
opportunity to clear up a lot of the
misconceptions regarding clandestine
drug synthesis that was kind of the the
most important thing for me to do but
then beyond that I wanted to tell drug
stories that hadn't been told and to
present a basic case for understanding
the value of these things you know and
there's a lot of different ways to do
that you can say that look this is
valued by an indigenous group and
they've integrated this into their
traditions and into their spirituality
and they really appreciate it
so maybe think twice before making it
illegal because these people are not
only not experiencing problems with it
it's making their lives better so think
very carefully before making a plant
illegal that's one basic idea that I
wanted to communicate but then the other
is these are real scientific tools you
know I've been on both sides of this
discussion journalistically I've had the
opportunity to interview enormous
numbers of people and to be interviewed
many many times and I've from being on
the opposite side from being interviewed
and profiled by people I've become aware
of how stupid a lot of these discussions
are and how easy it is for people to
minimize and reduce the importance of
all this as just drugs just drugs it's
drugs just drugs it's everything it's
your consciousness all of medicine
medicinal chemistry pharmacology this is
not a niche subject of study this is one
of the most important areas known to
mankind and has been for thousands of
years our medicines so so just to get
people at the very least even if they
don't like it to acknowledge its value
and to take it a little bit seriously
and not just say oh drugs just that
stuff that drug use use you know it's so
much more than that
so I've recommended this I've
recommended it there let's see a few
different pronunciations but Hamilton's
pharmacopoeia pharmacopoeia don't worry
about the spelling just search Hamilton
on your your favorite provider and
you'll find the show I watched on Amazon
Prime you can watch it anywhere there
are many many many different places
which episode might you suggest and I'm
gonna give you a few different profiles
a scientists start with and I know
that's really broad but let's just say
somebody who who would consider
themselves or who is professionally a
scientist it depends on what the there's
an episode from this most recent season
called a clandestine chemists tale and
that's about how the war on drugs has
made it more difficult for people to
have home labs partially that's one of
the ideas
trying to communicate it's also about
clandestine MDMA synthesis and features
the first ever televised total synthesis
of MDMA and it's real it's you know
that's what you see is a real synthesis
of MDMA so just the amazingness of even
capturing that on film is something that
I think is cool for almost anyone who
really wants to see this is where it
comes from this is how it's done you
know it goes we start with not we I
didn't but the chemist starts with you
know crude sassafras root bark oil and
takes it all the way down to the
recrystallized MDMA hydrochloride over
the course of five days and it's I was
just kind of blown away by watching that
process and I also televised a total
synthesis of quaalude and also we did a
little bit of a drug called gap box it
all got a little bit into LSD chemistry
I mean there's there's a lot of
chemistry I would say that drugs aside
there's probably more hardcore chemistry
in this TV show than there has ever been
in any TV show ever if anyone can find I
would be astonished if that's not the
case which is cool I mean I think it's
great because people find it interesting
and I get so many emails from people
saying that they find chemistry
interesting for the first time and the
way to do it wasn't to simplify it it
was to show people how complicated it
this well it's not only not dumbed down
but I love that routinely in these
episodes and I'd like to think of myself
as a reasonably well-read guy but I
haven't taken much chemistry you'll go
through a number of different diagrams
or they'll have that certain words will
come up and there is no pause for you
know a 10 minute explanation of the term
is just it's provided in context but it
is sophisticated sophisticated show but
still very entertaining to watch for
someone who is a non-scientist
let's just say they're fascinated by the
what they have read about psychedelics
or heard about psychedelics they've
never taken a psychedelic they find it
terrifying on some level the prospect is
there an episode or so as you'd
recommend well I'm so I'm probably the
worst person to ask because what the
things that I like in my own work are
always the things that are the most
obscure that no one has ever done but
that's from my own perspective whereas I
think the mushroom episode that I did
was the most successful of them all so
that's probably I guess that's the
people speaking they like that one the
most I that wouldn't be the first one I
would recommend but people want to learn
about mushrooms needs to be the first
one you would recommend probably a
clandestine chemists tail or the lazy
lizard school of hedonism episode about
this chemist who operated an MDMA lab in
the center of a volcano
so you mentioned which is a fantastic
episode you mentioned the mushrooms what
would have the other most popular
episodes been I think them people like
the episodes that detail shamanism I
think people are very interested in
shamanism partially because it's it's
non technical but because it's such a
foreign idea that you could have a
spiritual tradition based around drug
consumption and that it's so non taboo
that people do it with their families
and they do it to heal they they've just
never seen anything like that before and
I had neither until I saw it myself
what episodes would fall into that
category the mushroom episode the salvia
episode from season one both have that
and the San Pedro episode from season
two is a pretty in-depth analysis with
actually no voice over though it was a
different it had a different format from
the other episodes but it's it's a view
of cactus shamanism and Peru that I
think gives you an appreciation for the
medical context in the community that
this really is this is so different from
what you would think of when you would
hear this guy gives people mescaline
every night
you know these are people that are
treating him exactly the same way you
would treat a doctor in the United
States just I have epilepsy I have a
sprained ankle I mean I don't know what
he would call himself
watchu middle or a curandero but I mean
probably not shaman maybe he does but
I'm not sure how he would self-described
from that episode
what would he call himself do you think
mmm he may have called himself a shaman
though he did okay have I would have to
double-check maybe in English yeah I
mean a lot of those guys would sick what
I need or watch you mate or something
like that yeah this is not gonna make me
be relevant to anyone else but since I'm
curious did you actually have like
toilet [ __ ] or chicken [ __ ] splashed in
your face that episode because there was
a shot while you're doing your chores or
something awful and it was it was edited
in to your cleaning montage got splashed
on your glasses and it looked awful I
don't know if that was done in the
effects studio Hey okay you caught me
I couldn't resist that guy I have a
slightly childish sense of humor and and
and yeah it was just it's you had to
that's good yeah yeah it's documented my
again the that episode also features I
think perhaps my favorite Wardrobe of
yours which is otherwise fairly constant
but the gigantic yellow like Big Bird
hat yes that you're you're you're
dressed in towards the end I don't want
to give away too much you didn't look
too happy to be doing I guess
I'd imagine I haven't encountered this
directly in the in the San Pedro or
Wauchula cactus tradition that the
salado's where he was where he was
having you taken like Florida water or
whatever that was into your mouth to
spritz on him you did not look happy to
be doing that's so terrible have you
done that before
I have yeah you don't you don't want to
certainly don't want to drink it you
don't hold it in your mouth yeah it's
it's prob what probably 95% ethanol and
I lost the ability to taste for several
days after doing that it was it was
actually maybe one of the most damaging
things I did in the entire show was
holding the Florida water in my mouth
are you done what what if I do that yeah
what was one of the four people who
maybe so we talked about people who are
nervous or apprehensive yet curious what
about the overly confident cocksure
person who might go into something
without a healthy level of respect is
there is there an episode you'd
recommend the the DMT episode the opener
for that episode I think does a pretty
decent job of I've mu5 meö DMT yeah you
know I it's it's hard to say because
that's a great example and I've seen
that outside of my film work I've seen
someone who had a very cocky attitude
approach five Meo DMT is it's like I've
done a tense trip dude I've done ten
strip meeting LSD yeah I've done
whatever whatever I'm a there's nothing
that can I'm a veteran psycho nothing on
and and then you know it's a bad
attitude you don't want to enter any
experience with that attitude because
what what good could possibly come of
that so it's it's good to take things
seriously you don't want to be afraid
but it's a serious experience I mean
it's I would say it's no less serious
than being reborn so if you want to be
reborn with a angry cocky
confrontational attitude then go for it
but it's probably not the best approach
but you know that's the other thing is
I've had to cultivate a really less a
fair attitude toward a lot of things to
do my show effectively if you're going
to be a journal
and you're going to interview people you
can't constantly be telling them what's
right and what's wrong
and there's a lot of moralism and
there's a lot of psychedelic
prescriptivism in the community people
love to say you're doing it wrong you're
doing it you're not serious enough
you're just trying to get high it's not
respectful it's not traditional it's
abuse and I really hate to see that I
think that's one of the worst things
that somebody can do because ultimately
we're if you do that you're just a ping
the government's same mistakes of
setting up these rules of right and
wrong ways to use drugs so you can use
Marinol if it's prescribed by a doctor
and it's synthetic THC but you can't use
it from a plant that's the wrong way you
know all this you don't want to go down
that road of telling people what's right
and what's wrong
assuming they're not hurting other
people so I try not to tell people what
is right and what is wrong so if people
want to smoke five mio DMT with a cocky
attitude be my guest but it's it's it's
really anything that I say it's just you
know in an effort to minimize any harm
that could come from these substances
because it is a very serious experience
and it could be difficult what was what
was the scariest if you have any
scariest experience or unsettling
experience that you had not necessarily
I mean they're given the places that
you're going to I can think of a few
scenarios offhand I mean the kratom also
safety I mean my god there's so many
ways that you could put yourself into
difficult situations that are unrelated
to the psychedelic consump the
consumption of psychedelics themselves
but if were there any experiences you
had that were particularly difficult I
had I had one interesting experience
many years ago where I've been to China
for undercover reporting three times and
the first time I did it it was maybe
2012 something like that and I was going
undercover to a lab that was producing a
synthetic cannabinoid called you
1:44 which is a cool structure and and I
went to the lab interviewed the chemists
and they gave me a sample of the URM 144
so then I was back at my hotel room with
my cameraman who has Crohn's disease and
loves to be stoned he stoned all the
time and and and it helps him with
Crohn's but also he just loves to be
stoned and so he was saying you know
should we try out this you are 144 this
synthetic cannabinoid and I thought well
yeah yeah I suppose we should maybe give
it a little give it a little try but I
didn't have a scale and and typically I
would never use a drug without a scale
but I thought okay this has been used by
people before there's a little bit of
information on it I'll take one grain of
this granular crystal and and I'll smoke
it so I smoked a grain and he smoked a
grain and we were both sitting in our
hotel room and and starting to get very
very high and as I got more and more
high I started experiencing this fractal
of uncertainty where I was thinking I
don't know if this is you or 144 but
then I was thinking well even if it is
you are 144 I don't know anything about
you are 144 I don't know if it has toxic
metabolites I don't know if it is
carcinogenic I don't know if it has any
form of toxicity but even if it didn't
have those things I don't know if this
is pure you are 144 and if it isn't pure
I don't know anything about the toxicity
of those impurities but even if it is
pure and doesn't have toxic impurities I
don't know the dose that I consumed I
could have maybe consumed an overdose
and you know just going on and on and on
all the branching uncertainty about
safety and purity and potency and dose
and I was fine actually and actually
ended up having a good experience but it
just made me think you don't want to go
down the the fractal of uncertainty road
you don't want to you want to minimize
the uncertainty as much as you can
because your own mind is already
infinitely uncertain so why not at least
know that you've consumed you are 144
and though you've consumed one milligram
so you can at least rest on that
foundation so the negative experiences
that I've had have almost always been a
product of uncertainty and inadequate
preparation I would say that the
negative experiences that I have had
after carefully measuring doses have
typically been okay because I did have
that ability to fall back on
I took one point four milligrams
previously I'd taken 1 this is not going
to be that much stronger I'm gonna be ok
this will be it was over four hours last
time it's gonna be over four hours this
thing you also have the ability and the
training to assess or improve our
improve purity yourself that's true that
is true yeah so minimizing uncertainty I
think is really important but then some
of these things are more challenging in
five Meo DMT is an example of that you
know it has a an ability to to really
frighten people there's some people that
only have these negative experiences and
when I was using it most recently I
there's a chemist Casey Hardison who's a
friend of mine and he had gone out
drinking with a friend of his and after
drinking a little bit they decided to
smoke five Meo DMT together and and they
both smoked it at the same time which is
something that you shouldn't do you want
somebody watching over you and they both
dissociated because it has a sort of
dissociative character and when my
friend Casey came back his friend was
dead he had asphyxiated on his vomit
while he was in this state and there was
no one watching and I'm whole
yeah so that's a pretty frightening
thing to have happened and then I was
filming this piece about it and and I
remember talking to this guy an
ecologist turned toad venom shaman and I
was saying you know I really have some
reservations about this to be honest
with you because um you know this friend
of a friend very recently died and you
know the the fact that that happened is
it's frightening to me and he was saying
oh yes it was so terrible just terrible
and no one ever would have expected it
to happen to him because of course he
was the son of a shaman and and I was
saying oh I didn't realize he was the
son of a shaman that's interesting he's
saying oh you're talking about the
recent death in Brazil and I'm saying no
no this is a recent death in Colorado
there multiple recent deaths and you
know so just the fact that it's even
implicated in these deaths even though
it's not a direct effect the direct
toxic effect it's always people drowning
while they're dissociated or is fixating
on their vomit but just the fact that
this had happened at all was enough to
really give me some concerns about doing
it this is eventually drowning so I I
have to ask because I wanted to save it
for this conversation and it's part of
the reason that the the five Meo episode
opener is is so attention-grabbing why
on earth did the supposed shaman slash
facilitator choose a location with so
much water in so many rocks it's I have
gotten so much criticism for featuring
that and that's an interesting thing
about making these documentaries is that
there's a question of showing things the
way they are even if the way they are is
potentially unsafe or trying to always
set an example for other people because
you I don't want to misrepresent reality
and say things are a way that they're
not but at the same time that experience
showed me that you want to maybe set an
example I certainly got a lot of
criticism for it his reason for doing
his
his sessions by the waters I think
simply that it was a beautiful location
and the people that were smoking the
venom were very experienced so he
thought that they could handle it but
clearly there's a risk of drowning and
clearly you could hurt yourself on a
sharp rock or something like that I want
to revisit something we we chatted about
a little bit last night excited I had
asked you and feel free to correct my
recollection here why you hadn't
produced an episode with ayahuasca and I
don't remember this train of
conversation in the the truth barrel
sauna but I found what you said very
thought-provoking and I wanted to
explore it here I don't know if you
recall where we were picked up but it
was related to shamanism and the
providing of explanation I believe it
was or something along those lines and
the mention of uncertainty earlier
helped me to recall that portion of the
conversation but why not feature
ayahuasca well there's a number we can
get back to that I actually tried I
tried to do a story about the the death
of Kyle Millen I don't know if you know
that story because one of my concerns
again with Dogma and with prescriptivism
is that people start to say that there
is only one way to do things so when
ayahuasca was at the height of its
popularity in New York at least if you
said to someone I've done ayahuasca the
next question that would ask you is did
you do it in the Amazon and if the
answer is no then you didn't really do
ayahuasca did you you just did some
perversion of ayahuasca that shouldn't
be called ayahuasca and I found that
very obnoxious and elitist and stupid
because ayahuasca is a tea and it's a
tea that anyone listening to this can
make not that they should but they
assuming you can boil plants in water
and it's not a special knowledge to make
it so the idea that you have to go to a
foreign country and be with a different
culture to experience it I think is
flawed especially because a tourist
industry has emerged to satisfy this
enormous demand of white outsiders in
the Amazon I don't think there's
anything intrinsically wrong with drug
tourism but if the whole point of going
there is to have a traditional
experience and then what you're actually
having isn't traditional in the
slightest than what was the point of
travelling in the first place so what
one thing that happened is you had all
these white outsiders the there isn't
all that much anthropological literature
on the subject and they probably weren't
reading it to begin with so they don't
know what is traditional to begin with
so someone comes to a retreat in this
case it was a retreat called chambray
and the shaman says I'm actually a
Martian I'm always a promising start is
it no I mean this is a question so
you're a white outsider and somebody
says I'm a Martian yeah you don't want
it you don't appear racist right this
could be their tradition you don't know
what their tradition right maybe that
maybe they come from a long line of
Martians and and it would be very
offensive to question their Martian
heritage right you don't know for so
people know one wants to say anything so
people are getting away with saying
absolutely ridiculous things about
themselves just neglecting their duties
forget spiritual duties just their
duties is basically babysitters they're
not watching people and there was a
teenager named Kyle Nolan who went to
Peru to have one of these sorts of
experiences with a shaman named maestro
monk elute oh and he disappeared his
parents go to the retreat looking for
him the shaman says oh he just walked
away then they find his body buried in a
shallow grave on the outskirts of
retreat so as soon as that hits the news
and that was actually international news
was in tabloids I do remember one that
yeah then all these people come out of
the woodwork and say that that mike
strowman Clute oh I always knew there
was something up with him I always knew
there was something wrong he he would
say that he would just sit and watch
soap operas while everyone was on
ayahuasca he wasn't watching anyone and
and and something about that struck me
as being very dangerous that people
cared more about what they perceived as
being traditional than what was
effective or what was safe and if if he
had thought you know what this is a tea
and if I'm really interested in it maybe
I can brew a low dose batch of it myself
and test it out and figure this out on
my own I guarantee he was capable of it
and he would probably still be alive so
what was the cause of death was never
determined it was never determined
unfortunately so I don't and that's
often the case with these so so it's
really out of open mindedness that I
think that people should be aware
there's multiple ways to do these things
that it doesn't make your experience non
valid if it wasn't conducted in South
America but the other reason that you
were initially getting it is that you
know the mystery of existence or the
mystery of life is sort of the grand
mystery that we all must figure out for
ourselves and it's so difficult and
painful to think about your own
mortality and the death of the people
that you love and what the purpose of
life is that religions emerged to help
people deal with these big existential
questions and they help they help a lot
I think that's one reason that religions
are as popular as they are because it's
rough to sit alone in your apartment
scratching your head wondering what the
meaning of life is or something like
that and and so I understand why people
want these interpretive
conceptual frameworks for the
psychedelic experience and that's why
from the get-go in the 1960s it was you
know Zen Buddhism or the Tibetan Book of
the Dead or whatever any explanatory
framework that could be found was jumped
on because the reality that there is no
explanation is not all that palatable
but is unpalatable as it is I think that
that is the value exactly what makes it
difficult is what makes it valuable and
to have that experience and I say this
cautiously but to have that experience
by yourself with no one explaining
anything to you to be confronted by the
full magnitude of the mystery with an
absence of explanation is one of the
most powerful experiences that you can
have and I don't know if a shaman
prevents you from having that experience
they might not but I know that you will
have it if there's no one there to tell
you what's happening how have you found
it if you're comfortable sharing
positively powerful to sit with that
great uncertainty versus profoundly
destabilizing I mean and that's not I'm
not using that as a justification for
having this overlay of like a
shamanistic cosmology or anything like
that
in every experience but what is the I
guess internal the self-talk or anything
that allows you to helps you to turn
that into a positive experience as
opposed to a negative one or an
overwhelming one well if you can the
more that you can direct these things
toward values that will help your life I
think that that's generally good because
too much destabilization isn't healthy I
remember the first really really really
really strong ayahuasca experience I had
I had I had a bit of that I remember my
friend was watching Seinfeld in the
other room and and I
came out of it thinking and when you say
ayahuasca are you talking about the
varma wasicus pumping that of DMT with
mclubbe amide and and coming out of it
and thinking well that that was a
deconstruction of everything I have ever
known and ever will know I didn't know
who I was I didn't know what year was I
time had completely deconstructed I saw
my entire life is a book with each day a
page in the book and you know just these
profound Rican SEP xual is a shion's of
every aspect of being and then you come
out of it and what do you do do you go
and join your friend and watch Seinfeld
I think that'd be very difficult to do I
don't know or maybe maybe the easiest
thing in the world I bet I was inside
your experience at them what did you do
I apprehend Civ Lee watched some
Seinfeld and then decided against the
sign cause and what did you what did you
gain from that experience if anything I
mean what did you take from that well
it's okay here's what I would say about
that experience is that I am NOT I I
don't know what to do with experiences
of that magnitude and I'm reluctant to
find a framework that explains it so I
don't know that it's especially
beneficial I don't think it was damaging
but I can say that at lower doses
ayahuasca has had much more practical
benefit and sometimes almost
cartoonishly practical could you give an
exactly yes I remember once I taken a
low dose I believe was 45 milligrams of
DMT with 300 milligrams of mclubbe amide
and and I was writing and I was really
enjoying everything that I was writing
and I was thinking damn I'm getting some
good writing done I'm really working
through ideas in an effective way
I'm loving this but you know what would
make it
much better is a little nicotine gum
because I like nicotine gum and that
will make my thoughts sharper that will
give me enhanced clarity and it will
make my writing even better if I'm
chewing nicotine gum and then I looked
at the nicotine gum and I thought but
then this is the thought that underlies
all addiction this is the thought that
underlies all compulsive behaviors I
want more it's not good enough the way
it is I want it to be that much better
but it will never be good enough and the
nicotine gum is already inside me I can
create my own nicotine gum and I drew
matically through the nicotine gum
across the room it's like I don't need
this I already am the nicotine gum and
and you know that's I think why these
things can have an anti addictive effect
one of the reasons is you know there's
all sorts of pharmacological reasons but
even psychologically they teach you that
all these things are inside you and that
you have the ability to create these
sorts of drug effects on your own to
some extent that it's all you know it's
it's your acetylcholine receptors that
are being activated you can activate
them on your own you know it's it's a
flashback to Shogun with the sugar
crystals on the right which that's
amazing I've never heard that story
right yeah yeah so that's a very
practical thing is don't chew nicotine
gum to make your writing better because
it's already inside you and you just can
create it yourself and I've had so many
of those those sorts of low-level
practical experiences and I really like
that because it's not about time like
what can I tell you about how my sense
of time was deconstructed I can go on
and on about it and you wouldn't
understand and I wouldn't understand
and it's exist outside of the realm of
any sort of comfortable comprehension at
least for me where as thoughts about
addiction about how you construct your
life about how you ration your love or
how much love you have or how to
integrate love into your existence those
are things that you have practical
applications and I think that's
important are the practical applications
so this may or may not be a good segue
but I'm going to give it a shot anyway
I know nothing of wade-davis I don't
know if if you'd be open to describing
who Wade Davis is and perhaps further
more defining the cultural matrix by who
is Wade Davis Wade Davis was a student
of Richard Evans shultiess at Harvard he
was an ethno botanist who came to
prominence in the 80s after writing a
book called the Serpent and the rainbow
and for the hosts later made into later
made into a movie by Wes Craven and
proposing this pretty outrageous idea
that the idea of zombies in Haiti was
not only real in the sense that there
really was Zomba fication this wasn't
some kind of folk legend but that there
was a intricate pharmacological
explanation for how these zombies were
created that involved scopolamine and
the toxin from pufferfish TTX so really
amazing idea
he got a huge amount of criticism for it
at the time of its publication and was
even accused of fraud and or
contaminating his samples with TTX to
prove his hypothesis was very very
controversial at the time but it's such
an interesting idea and it hadn't been
adequately tested I wanted to go back
and did in 2009 to collect samples just
to see if anyone else could find further
evidence for what he said because that's
one thing that people do all the time is
endlessly debate is it real is it not
real instead of just going out and
trying to see for yourself and collect
new samples and do additional analysis
and figure it out but he he's had a lot
of luck I'll tell you that he's he's one
of these guys where the number of crazy
things that he collected in his career
it borders on being suspicious and I
understand why people regard him with
suspicion because he's first of all he's
a great storyteller
which
makes maybe people maybe regard him with
suspicion for that reason as well
because he's not dry and serious enough
but you know he discovered a fungus
called dikteon Nima Huaorani
that contains it's a sort of a lichen
that contains psilocybin crazy no one
else has ever found the species he just
happened to find it no one else has ever
found it amazing he also claims to have
found the tallest San Pedro cactus ever
observed it was I think a hundred feet
tall okay that one strikes me is
unbelievable but I've examined the
specimen at the Harvard herbarium myself
and read his descriptions of it I you
know I think maybe didn't bring a tape
measure with him and made a little bit
of a generous estimation of its height
but he but he really also was by all
accounts a very hard worker and really
was you know out there talking to people
he was a prolific writer and made a lot
of really amazing discoveries was the
field exploration and sort of the
cultural examination is that something
that you try to emulate or is that yeah
I mean it seems like that's a strong
component of at least the TV show sure I
can tell the there's another compound
that I wanted to chat about which is
I've again we didn't we didn't really
get into it yesterday over dinner but
can you perhaps introduce people to what
ibogaine is and why it why it might be
of interest or is of interest yes so
ibogaine is an alkaloid that is found in
the roots of a Central West African
plant called tavern Anthea boga and it's
a pretty amazing molecule it's very very
difficult to synthesize
all the ibogaine that's used
commercially has to be extracted from
plants it's very complicated
structurally and pharmacologically it is
one of the most complicated drugs I've
ever read about but the reason that
people are interested in ibogaine is
there was a guy named Howard lots of who
was addicted to heroin
he tried i began sort of on a whim and
then afterwards lost his desire to use
heroin and patented it as an anti
addictive intervention for treatment of
heroin addiction so it's a pretty
amazing thing i mean one of the most
difficult pharmacological tasks is
getting people off of opioids to the
point that to some extent people have
thrown up their hands and said alright
the best we can do is a Guinness for
placement therapy will give them
methadone will give them buprenorphine
and we're just giving them another
opioid that's regulated and that's the
best treatment we have when it comes to
actually getting people off of it there
are very they're really there's nothing
in terms of pharmacotherapy there's you
know clinics that specialize in helping
people wean off of it but we don't have
drugs that are designed to reduce the
addictiveness of the opioid itself so it
seems to have that effect for a lot of
people unfortunately hasn't been studied
as well as I would hope because it's a
Schedule one drug in the United States
which has interfered with scientific
research but but what's really amazing
about ibogaine is even though it's
famous for its treatment of opioid
addiction is that I think it has a a
general anti addictive anti compulsive
effect it also works for alcoholism it
also works for methamphetamine addiction
it seems to work for many compulsive
behaviors does it only have that
persistence of effect at high doses that
is a question that hasn't been
thoroughly investigated but my guess is
that there are alternative dosing
oh geez that are safer than taking
single high doses of Shore to his flood
doses and that would be micro dosing
over longer periods of time or taking
lower doses over longer periods of time
and this is especially useful because
ibogaine is cardiotoxic and has been
associated with a number of deaths so
any way to reduce that toxicity is a
boon to the therapeutic use of the
substance
are there other outside of addiction are
there other applications or potential
applications of I begin that people are
exploring or hypothesizing yes so one of
the most interesting things that that I
have researched regarding ibogaine is
its effect on a protein called G DNF
that's glial derived neurotrophic factor
and this is a protein that is very
useful in the treatment of Parkinson's
disease there's been some limited
clinical work where they show that it
can cause a regrowth of dopaminergic
neurons and which is the mechanism of
Parkinson's damage to the brain is loss
of dopaminergic neurons so it's directly
reversing the toxic effect of
Parkinson's and they found that ibogaine
causes a release of the same therapeutic
protein so that's pretty damn useful and
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
with it I mean it also seems to
synergize with dopaminergic drugs so
it's possible that it increases patient
sensitivity to the l-dopa treatment as
well and on top of that it seems to have
an antidepressant effect and depression
is one of the major symptoms of
Parkinson's disease so I think it could
really be helping people with
Parkinson's and there's a sort of
underground community of people with
Parkinson's that use ibogaine and and I
occasionally receive emails from these
sorts of people it's often they use it
at 20 milligrams a day and they seem to
really believe in it as a treatment and
and on one hand
it's irresponsible to talk about these
things without a lot of serious medical
support but the flipside is that it
needs to be studied people need to be
aware of it and it's very sad to see the
same treatments being used for
Parkinson's and today that were used
3040 years ago I mean it's still pretty
much take l-dopa wait till it stops
working and then we'll switch you on to
something else but there's no treatment
available it's actually addressing the
root cause of the neuro degeneration and
if this does and patients are being
deprived that treatment it's a tragic
thing you mentioned in the beginning of
your description of ibogaine that it's
extracted from plants and it is
difficult to synthesize very very
difficult yeah and this is I'm so glad
to have you on the show from for their
many many reasons but also just to
discuss this the spectrum of scientific
material it's not on a strip that's
right description all the way to say
shamanistic practices and so on but
there's because while watching the five
Meo DMT episode and the the capturing of
toads and also your commentary at the
end made me think or contemplate how one
of the weaknesses of the argument for
whole plants is that or squeezing toads
for that matters it seems very
environmentally unsustainable and if the
objective is to get some of these
compounds to I mean you could have farms
like they do in Brazil for santo Diamond
where they have ayahuasca vines for just
Hector's and Hector's and actors but oh
wow it's amazing have you seen that I
haven't seen it but I know I know a guy
who knows a guy but is there is one of
the arguments for synthesis that it is
just a more scalable solution if one
wants to like let's just say maybe not
in the case of
Parkinsons although it is widespread but
for OCD or utilizing some of these
psychedelic compounds if they were to be
rescheduled or derivatives developed
that were not scheduled one the
synthetic route is more it's the
sustainable option compared to using
naturally occurring plants and so on I
mean is that I don't know the the
realities of extracting or synthesizing
have done neither but I mean is that is
that something that you thought about
Wahl quite a lot while making the show
or it's something that came up a lot
like kratom is another example right I
mean I just it's seeing the kind of
devastation and the the conflicts
between I don't know if you'd call them
kratom poachers and people who are
attempting to preserve some of these
last existing forests I mean it's it's
the so much violence so much destruction
yeah this synthesis fix that
sustainability of course does matter and
synthesis is typically more sustainable
but the other thing is that you know all
these plants are genetic reserves that
if we're just looking at them as a crop
and not appreciating them as something
to conserve and study then we may be
losing the opportunity to discover all
sorts of new things you know I'm sure
there is our old ayahuasca vines that
contain beta kar billions that have
never been found before and if we're
just chopping them down to use them in a
brew when you could just as easily use
Syrian ruin mhmm Allah or something like
that you have to wonder whether or not
were potentially losing the opportunity
or they could be you know useful
cultivars they might be faster growing
there's all sorts of reasons to keep and
study plants as opposed to just using
them up it's saying it is true of peyote
there's so many different alkaloids and
there's been very little study done in
terms of finding you know faster growing
varieties of peyote or finding strains
that have a higher mescaline content or
a higher peyote and content or things
like that
and if we wanted to make these things
available those would be necessary
things to do in the same way that
they've been done with cannabis you
don't just grow any cannabis you grow
cannabis that has been bred to have the
qualities that you're looking for
typically high THC content but there's a
lot of other things high THC V or high
CBD content and and so you know I think
that that's really important you want to
have natural reserves of these things
that that can be studied and can be used
as stock for breeding and you risk
losing all of that if you're just
thinking only in the moment I want it
now same is true of these toads and
there's a lot of basic scientific
questions that haven't been answered
about the toads I would love to see
people you know studying the rate that
they regenerate the venom or how they
respond to the milking or if they're
sensitive to their own venom which is
such a fascinating question because with
you know with pufferfish they've
actually evolved a mutation in their
sodium ion channel that makes them
insensitive to the toxicity of TTX is
the same true of the five ht1 a receptor
in the bufo alvarius toad have they also
evolved a different type of serotonin
receptor that makes them insensitive to
their own venom I mean those are the
sorts of things that I would love to be
doing with the toads answering these
basic scientific questions when it comes
to just using them as a source of drugs
you can make five Meo DMT from melatonin
and it's so much more efficient and so
much cheaper probably as well that it
just seems that without a good reason
why even potentially harass a toad and
then on top of that you have the
certainty regarding dose which is so
wonderful to be able to say this is
exactly 15 milligrams of five Meo DMT
freebase as opposed to this is a hundred
milligrams of toad venom that might
contain who knows how much five Meo DMT
and however much five Meo nmt or
serotonin Oh sulfate or whatever
asteroid a lactone that's found you know
if there's a lot of stuff in there and
it's rarely looked at
objectively or quantified in any way so
the people that are using it don't
really know what they're getting I'm
gonna pause for a second for just a
remedial definition for me and anyone
who might be curious because a word has
popped up a number of times that I've
read a thousand times alkaloid mmm-hmm
can you define what an alkaloid is sure
in the strictest sense an alkaloid is a
material isolated from a plant that
contains a basic nitrogen atom so that's
an alkaloid sometimes the term is
extended to include any material that's
extracted from a plant but in the
strictest classical definition THC would
not be an alkaloid because it doesn't
contain a nitrogen atom Salvador and a
would not be an alkaloid because it
doesn't contain a nitrogen atom
terpenoid no yeah that's another thing
that I did I understand but I've read
yeah yeah so so that's it it's it's a
term mostly derived from the classical
methods of extraction from plants so all
these drugs that have basic nitrogen
atoms behave in a certain way chemically
and can be extracted from plants using
an acid-base extraction and so that's
how they get this name thank you
no that's this is this is the type of
education that i need but i won't i
won't take up the podcast to do that
i'll be looking at the the book
recommendations love to i know we have
not too too much time left and i'm
keeping an eye on time but your shift to
smart drugs no tropics and nootropics
i'm not sure how to pronounce that
either are there any particular types of
cognitive han sirs that you find
interesting and one which maybe you can
recall the name of came up in one of
your episodes in fact because it was
described in a handful it by one of the
chemists i think it was the same chemist
to harold Amer yes II D to C D yeah all
right are there any particular
cognitive enhancers that you have found
effective and/or interesting it's such a
it's such a philosophically interesting
question because whenever people say
that something made them smarter I
always think of the dunning-kruger
effect are you familiar don't know what
that is it's a these two psychologists
at Cornell I believe found this effect
that the the more competent someone is
in a given task whether it's musical
ability or humor the more likely they
are to underrate their ability and the
less competent they are the more likely
they are to overrate their ability so I
always wonder you know what would it
what would be the manifestation of a
true cognitive enhancer would it make
you feel stupid would it make you feel
increases aware of all the things you
don't know would you feel intellectually
ashamed of yourself anivia true smart
drugs have all been abandoned because
they actually made people feel abysmally
stupid there's a major problem with
self-assessment in the realm of
nootropics
just because something makes you feel
smarter does not mean that you are
smarter and then there's a larger
question of how do we define
intelligence what does it mean to be
smart is having an improved memory does
that mean that you're smarter is being
more creative a sign of intelligence
it's typically not included in any kind
of objective measure of intelligence so
so how do you define it to begin with
and what are these drugs doing and what
is the intended effect it's a it's a
really complicated question you know the
most basic thing I think is memory
that's the thing that most people can
agree if they had a better memory it
would be useful and I do believe that
some of these things you know often some
of the most mundane things like nicotine
improve memory and aid focus a little
bit so of all the things that I've tried
in the
nootropics and its many the one that I
still use is just nicotine gum I try to
use it less I sometimes don't use it at
all I know I told that story about not
using it but I still I still chew it on
occasion because it really helps me read
especially if I'm going you know plowing
through it a dense novel or something I
like to go to the library and hop in a
square nicotine gum and and just really
try to focus but you know new pepped was
okay PRL 8:53 was okay
fennel piracetam is okay they're all you
know typically it's the stimulating ones
that are a little bit better but then
then the questions are these nootropics
or are they simply stimulants and our
stimulants nootropics how do we
designate these things
it's what have you tried to CD I have
yes absolutely and two CDs really
interesting because one thing if you
read about people new modest speak with
photographic memories one thing they all
seem to have in common is they're all
synesthetes right and one thing I've
wondered about that
synesthesia that they have is is this
multi-sensory cross-linking of
information aiding recall because if
just for people listening to just to
define that term so it's if people who
may smell colors or visualize numbers
that's the type of cross-linking that
you see in these like the mind of Annie
minused by AJ Lauria gets into this in
great depth but sorry to interrupt
please continue right so so yeah so yeah
if when you think of an orange it's not
just an orange it's the color it's the
smell it's the taste it's the sound it's
the texture and there's all this
multi-sensory encoding of the
information does that allow you to
recall the orange in a different way or
do you have more handles on that memory
that allow you to retrieve it more
easily
so psychedelics also induce synesthesia
and that was one question that I had is
could this synesthesia inducing effect
be harnessed in order to aid
retention of information and I don't
have a real answer to that question but
I think that if drugs like to CB do have
any sort of nootropic effect it may be
as a result of that kind of I mean
there's different ways that may be
encouraging synesthesia would be one way
another way might be just a basic
stimulant effect another way it might be
that they cause you to approach problems
from a different perspective and this is
why James Fadiman Wright is very
interested in psychedelics in problem
solving is because sometimes having a
different way is all that it takes not
necessarily a better way not necessarily
a smarter way simply a different way of
looking at something is all it takes to
solve that problem because you got
locked into a certain way of approaching
it you're only thinking about it one way
and just to mix it up to shuffle the
deck for a moment and think well maybe I
could have done this in a completely
different way is what it takes
gyms great he's really fun to chat with
- yeah about the the the studies that
they had conducted related to the the
problem-solving with with hard sciences
and a lot of engineering problems eight
for people interested I also spoke with
Jim on the podcast so you can find the
fad of an episode pretty easily but for
you personally and if you had nicotine
gum currently in pole position would you
put anything in second and third place I
think you know the classics nicotine
caffeine just like caffeine anhydrous or
I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing yeah
thank you are you sweet and you know
good old-fashioned ritalin on occasion I
say this with a little bit of reluctance
because stimulants are addictive and and
it's kind of a bad habit to get into but
I would be dishonest if I didn't
acknowledge the fact that using low dose
Ritalin has helped me what is low dose
mean ten milligrams I don't take it
every day but
it's you know it's it's a tricky one
because it does give you a certain
intellectual stamina that helps you read
and write and think and I think that
with a lot of discipline you could
achieve those same effects without
ritalin but it's helped me you mentioned
something that I want to come back to
just for a moment for people who might
be listening and interested if they're
if they want to assess before and after
effects on cognition I was you can find
online tests that are used in studies to
to assess reaction time working memory
things of that type so if if one were
proactively looking at the before and
after effects of just about anything in
your room on tape or alcohol doesn't
really matter there are tests if you
look up some of the studies done by any
number of cognitive neuroscience
Kahneman and others where you can you
can identify online tests that can give
you it will help you to establish a
baseline if you want to look at some of
the effects yeah but yeah the the
intelligence can be fine sliced into so
many different component areas right I
mean it we can get really really complex
for people who are who would be I was
actually involved with a study people
should check this out he's also been on
the podcast adam Ghazali out of UCSF at
the Ghazali lab they developed a
software called neuro eraser that was
very very effective they ended up I
think it was the cover of nature at one
point being able to reverse certain
aspects of age-related cognitive decline
and then after the cessation of training
was software there's a persistence of
effect I want to say at least six months
later it was really remarkable so there
are tests you can use to assess if the
effects of these types of compounds
well Hamilton we could go on or I I
could go on for hours and hours and
hours but
I suppose we should probably wrap up in
just a little bit where can people find
you say hello and otherwise learn about
your work yeah I mean I have a Twitter
at Hamilton Morris and Instagram at
Hamilton Morris I'm starting a website
Hamilton Morris calm but it's not up yet
my prediction is that we will have it up
the Royal we in this case meaning
Hamilton people I might introduce you to
by the time that this goes live so
Hamilton Morris comm Hamilton Morris
condo home and if you want to watch my
TV show Hamilton's pharmacopoeia it
committee purchased for three dollars an
episode on iTunes and Amazon and it's
also free on Hulu and it's on National
Geographic and vice land and I'm sure
you can also torrent it as well if you
have Amazon Prime I think it's actually
available with Prime membership ok as
well is there anything do you have any
ask of the audience is there anything
that people can help you with besides
the TV show yeah if you know I self fund
a lot of the scientific research that I
do so if there are any psychedelic
philanthropists out there that are
interested in funding non-clinical
basic science research that's chemistry
and pharmacology with no clinical and
insight but are just interested in
understanding the mechanisms of these
substances reach out to me because in a
chemistry lab a couple thousand bucks
can go a long way and it's it's always
important to remember that without the
basic science the clinical work can't
really be done to what type of research
would if somebody's listening and says
you know what I don't have a lot of
money but I could probably dig up two to
five K for something interesting what
might that be applied to right now I'm
working with the chemist named Jason
Wallach and we are trying to do a
process called autoradiography where you
take a radio label drug and you look at
the distribution in the brain and we're
looking specifically at
drug that seems to distort the way sound
is perceived based on Sheldon's reports
and we want to see with the radio label
drug how it will distribute in a rodents
brain so we're trying to raise a little
bit of money to do that sort of research
it's not all that expensive and it could
really have interesting bearing on our
understanding of auditory perception we
do have time to get into Oliver Sacks
but have you read music Ophelia I
haven't read it I think you would love
it I have to yeah it's almost entirely
about auditory pathologies of various
types but I think you would you would
greatly greatly enjoy it we did not have
a chance to get into Oliver's actually
did not have a chance to get into
Claudio not alcohol is that a say the
name yeah maybe another time he's
amazing so for people who might be
interested in helping you with with some
of the science I would encourage them to
first go to Hamilton Moore's calm it may
be unavailable but there may be a
contact form on there by the time that
is ready and if not is Twitter generally
the best way yeah to contact you do you
have any other recommendations
suggestions parting words book
recommendations anything at all
I'd like to say or share I really can't
overestimate the value of peak Hall for
understanding these things it's just a
fantastic book it will tell you almost
everything you need to know about
psychedelics and drugs in general and
it's a really great love story and if
yeah it's it's it's a moving experience
to read it so I hope everyone will run
out and buy a copy I think it's 15 bucks
or something
YP Cullen not tikal oh because the first
one at night if you like pee call I
think he'll move on to tea call I would
hope and I've also not surprisingly in
almost every office I have been to with
researchers who were involved in these
fields they have P : t call right there
prominently displayed either in front of
or right above exactly where they sit
and I'm embarrassed to say I haven't
read it because
I feared that I would perhaps like
taking the ultimate smart drug see just
how ignorant I am and become overwhelmed
by the the chemistry so it's nice to
know that you can read it in multiple
passes and get different things from it
yeah absolutely
well Hamilton thank you so much thank
you for the time today I would encourage
everybody to watch the show it is
spectacular
I don't know which I would recommend
people start with I particularly enjoyed
and have enjoyed recommending the b5
amiyo DMT that the the ketamine episode
also I thought was just beautifully shot
and edited and crafted yeah it was
really well done and all I mean all of
them that I've seen have been
exceptionally exceptionally well done
and I don't say that lightly thank you
but I encourage everybody to check out
there's no reason not to the episodes
are very short very digestible included
the opening animation for the series it
was a group of animators advice actually
it's spectacularly yeah it was there was
a guy named James Blagdon and he sort of
contributed this style and then it was a
number of different animators advice
that executed it and they did a great
job on that on that fine closing note
thank you to everybody listening thank
you for taking the time and I'll make
one last request of the audience which
is if you would perhaps like to hear
Hamilton do his own podcast let him know
I think I think it would be a gift to
the world to hear some of the interviews
you have done an extended form so
that'll be my plea to the universe that
maybe someday you put some of your audio
out there for people to hear
yes I'll consider it alright guys until
next time the show notes yeah we will
include links to everything the books
mentioned the studies that were
conducted or I should say that conducted
and published by shulgin including his
self experimentation methodology I will
figure out the best length for that the
Fadiman episode teamed up blog for
Fadiman f ad ima n and you can find
links to Hamilton and everything else
that we covered today at Tim goth log
forward slash podcast hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
leadership in turbulent times which is
the latest book by the ever amazing
Pulitzer Prize winning author Doris
Kearns Goodwin I had another podcast not
too long ago and she just blew everyone
away what an incredible story teller and
Wever of history and lessons from
history you can check that out if you
want a to Knoblauch forward slash Doris
your is it was a captivating
conversation that really blew me away
leadership and turbulent times that is
the latest book is a culmination of five
decades of acclaimed studies in
presidential history which offers an
illuminating exploration of the early
development at super key early
development growth and exercise of
leadership and draws upon four
presidents before get to in a second
Goodwin asks and answers in those pages
the question our leaders born or made
where does ambition come from how does
adversity affect the growth of
leadership does the leader make the
times or do the times make the leader
and she draws upon the four presidents
she has studied most closely namely
Abraham Lincoln Theodore Roosevelt
Franklin D Roosevelt and Lyndon B
Johnson to show how they recognize
leadership qualities within themselves
and were recognized as leaders by others
and I mentioned early development being
cubics it goes back to their first so
germs and experiments of attempts at
engaging with policy and public life and
covers their failures their near misses
and lessons learned so it applies to
anyone who is trying to make a study of
leadership or how they can better over
use both themselves and others it's
important to underscore no common
pattern describes completely a single
trajectory of leadership although set
apart and background abilities in
temperament these four men shared a
fierce ambition and deep-seated
resilience that enabled them to surround
uncommon hardships that their best all
four were guided by a sense of moral
purpose this seminal work provides an
accessible and essential roadmap for
aspiring established leaders in every
field I highly highly recommend it for
more information you can visit Doris
Kearns Goodwin com that's Doris Kearns
ke a RNs Goodwin comm and leadership in
turbulent times is available in
hardcover ebook and audio wherever books
are sold
this episode is brought to you by Inc
tel I've used them personally ever since
I wrote before our work week I've been
asked over and over again how I choose
to delegate tasks how I do 80/20
analysis and so on at the root of many
of those decisions is a simple question
actually two questions number one how
can I invest money to improve my quality
of life I use that an investing as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant in Stella is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
unit I used Intel during the launch of
the 4-hour body which was very very
involved and they provided 24/7 customer
service for my land rush campaign
because it was critical for me to take
care of every person who purchased my
books and participated this allowed me
to focus on the things that I am better
at my strengths like the marketing plan
that we'd worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
and out and make your customers raving
fans they answer more than a million
customer service requests every year and
they can do so across all platforms
including email phone social media text
even chat leaving your customers with
the Forest Service or just mediocre
service which by the way in a
competitive war is a huge liability long
wait times or unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business APL removes the logistics and
headaches of this type of communication
allowing you to focus on your strengths
and grow your business it can be a real
competitive advantage and I see many
many e-commerce companies and tech
companies thinking of customer service
as a good enough check box or an
afterthought and just like Airbnb is
design and innovative ways to be a
competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off
discount $10,000 off your startup fees
and costs by visiting in telecom forward
slash Tim so check it out for more info
go to Inc telecom I NK t PL comm forward
slash